uh always look for these wrist locks in
here the people uh
will forget them and they should always
pay for touching you let's say let's say
I go for the wrist lock and he pulls his
arm out now because he's he's trying to
do uh
his stuff and you know create openings
do you see that as he has to protect
himself on the ground
right and uh let's say uh I'm doing this
kind of stuff right and he's got no
choice but to try to create space with
the other arm because I'm pinning it and
he's got no space here so as he goes to
create space Oh that's where I'm
attacking the wrist you see and so from
that from that wrist attack I'm I'm
still attacking the wrist
DC as I'm going into the mouth it is a
much easier mount
then I'm trying to mount and he has pure
100 defense